حلقه جديده يشهدها مسلسل التطبيق الاكثر
جدلا في الولايات المتحده تيك توك مدير
تنفيذي سابق للشركه
يرفع دعوى قضائيه بعد عده سنوات من فشل
الوصول الى تسويه مع الشركه
الفصل غير المشروع كان الشكوى الاولى التي
قدمها
والتي اتخذتها الشركه بسبب كشفيو لمخطط
عالمي لسرقه الملكيه الفكريه لشركات اخرى
والربح منها
من بين الادعاءات الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
دعوى السيد يوغو ان مكاتب باي دانس في
بكين لديها وحده خاصه من اعضاء الحزب
الشيوعي الصيني يشار اليها باسم اللجنه
مهمتها مراقبه التطبيقات الشركه وارشاد
الشركه لتطبيق القيم الشيوعيه الاساسيه
وامتلاك مفتاح الموت الذي قد يؤدي الى
ايقاف تشغيل التطبيقات الصينيه
ولعل اكثر ما اكد الشكوك الامريكيه حول
التطبيق ادعاء السيد يوم ابقاء اللجنه ضمن
دائره الوصول الفائق الى جميع بيانات
الشركه حتى البيانات المخزنه في الولايات
المتحده
تظهر ادعاءات السيد يو كذلك ان مهندسي
شركه نسخوا مقاطع فيديو ومنشورات من
تطبيقات كسناب شات وانستجرام ثم نشروها
دون اذن والهدف كما يدعي السيد ديو خلقه
جيش من الروبوتات لتعزيز ارقام المشاركه
ورفع قيمتها السوقيه باسرع وقت ممكن
خلال الاشهر التي عمل فيها سيدو من عام
2017 الى 2018 شهد على تعديل الخوارزميات
لرفع محتوى يعبر عن كراهيه اليابان بجعل
المنشورات اكثر بروزا للمستخدمين يبدو ان
الفوضى داخل الشركه بدات تتسرب فبعد ان
طالت المؤسس تهم برشوه مسؤول كبير مكلف
بتنظيم الانترنت في الصين في 2018
ها هي الشركه تتلقى ضربه موجعه وتتهم
بالخروج عن القانون في دوله يستخدم
تطبيقها اكثر من 150 مليون امريكي كرم
حناوي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات